S
AN THE SILENCE ANY AND ALL
SSENT.
SECRETARY OF STATEIKE POMPE
YOU SAI SOMETHING THA CAUT
MYNTEREST.
DR. FAUCI W EVYTHING Y
SAW.
YOU ME TO A DIFFERT
NCLUON THANHAT HE WAS
SAYING PUBCLYND WHATS IT
TH TM TRYING TO SENCE THE
STATE PARTNT?
>> SEAN, TNKSOR HAVG M ON
TONIT.
HE WOULDAVE EN EVERYTHG
AT I'S TOPIC TRE WE A
OLEUNCH OF FOLKSHOOULD
HAVE SEEN THE ME INFORMATION
HEUBLICLY STATED
I  KW HOW ANYDY COULD HAVE
SEEN BY MARC AND APRIL OF 20
W ANYONE COULD HAV SEEN THE
CUMULATED EVIDCE SURROUNDING
THE WUHAN INITUTE OF VIROLY
AND CCLUDE THAT TRE WAS NOCHAN D
OM TS PLACE.
E EVIDENCE CONNUES TO GW.
I HRD D FAUCI SAY, IHINKTHEHINEE
TO COME CLE ABO THIS.
TH IS CRAZY NAÏVE GUSH O THAT
ERY INCENTIVE  DO AT TY
DI I989, WHICH W KILLED
THOUNDSF TIR OWN PEOPLE.
THISAS RESULTED IN THE DEAS
OFILLIS OF PEOPLE AUND T
WORL
I D'T UNDERSTAND . FAUCI
CONTUING TO COUNT GIVIN CHINA
THENEFIT O THE DOU WHEN
THEY HAVE W SENSED EARD OF
AND WHILE THEY WERE BREAKINTO
KE SE THAT THE STA
DERTME, THE DID NANT US
TO COMETE T TASK.
>> Sean: BICAL WHAT YOU'R
SANG, IT WOULD EXPIN WHY IT
WAS EITHERPRILR MAY THAT
TRUMKA STATED PUBLICLY TT IT
LILY CAME FROM T LAB, WCH
EVERYBODY KNE WAS INVOLVED IN
THEAIN OF FUNIONESEAH.
D I INVOLVE WIT
COROVIRUS'.
IT KIND OF MAK SENSE, DOESN
IT
>> IT DOES,EAN.
THE EVIDEN WASIRCUMSTANTIAL.
IT WASROWING IN THE EDENCE
THAT THIS WA A TRANSMISSN
ISE WAS ALMOS NONEXTENT.
SOE HEARD WHATRESINT TRUMP
SAID.
WHAT I SAI IN EAR MAY OF
20.
WE SAID THAT THERE W ENORMOUS
EVIDEN THA THIS W A ESCAPEFROM Y
THAT WASEING OPETED IN
DANGEROUWAY.
AND OBAB STILLS TO THIS
DAY, ANY INDICION.THIS IS REAL I
ONING.
WE NEED TO GET TO THE BOTM OF
I DON'T SEE AN EFFORT FROM T
BIN ADNISTRATION TOAKE
THIS SERIOLY.THERE'S ENOOUS COSS
ST PUTTINGHE AMERICAN PEOPLE
RISK.
>> Sean: WE VE BIG
INVESTMENTQUIT FIR, GOLDMAN
SAS, DEUTSCHE BA, JPMorgan
CHASE.
EY KIND OF KN WHATHEYRE
DOG.
I HAV YETO SEE ANY EVINCE
TH HUNTER BIDEN HAD ANY
AT ALL KIND O LIKHEN H WENT
ON "GOODORNI ARICA" AND
ADMITTED H HAD NO EERIENCE IN
ENERGYOIL, GAS, OR UKRAINE.
AND THE QSTION WAS,H, WHY
MONEY?Y GIVE Y ALLF THIS
I N'T KNOW, HEAID.
COD ITE THAT YR FATR W
VICERESIDENT?
OBABLY.
EP WORK THAT WASIS AWER.
NOW WE HAVE THE ISSUEERE.
NO, 1 BILLION-DOLR DEAL
WITH THE BANKF CNA.
OK.
THAN W GOT $100,000HOPPING
SPREFROM CHISEATIONAL.
NOW, DON'T KNOW TT
MR. SECRARY,T MAY BEUST
BELIEVINVOING THAT LAW AND I
DOTELIEVE IN TAKI THIS
FOR FREE.
I DOTHINK A CHINESE
NATIONALOULDVER GIVE ANYBOWATCHT
100 AND TO TAKE EIR MILY
SWEETHEA DEAL AND BYPS, OH,
LDMAN SACHS AN DEUTSCH BK
D GO WITH HUNDRED BAG --
HUNDREDAG- HUNTER BEN.
>> THE CHINE CALMNESS PTY I
VERY STREGIC.
-- COMNISTARTY IS VERY
RATEGIC.
THEYERE PROVIDINGESOUES
MONEY TO HUNR BEN.
THERE W SOMETHING TY THOUGHTTHEN
THE'S  EVIDENCE TT THA
S FANCIAL EXPERTI OR
EXPERTE INIS FIELD.
WHENOU HR VE PRESIDENT
BIDE SAY I NEVER TALK AUTTHE BUS
ITEEMS JUST ENCOASSE ITS
AT THOSE TOPIC DID N ARI.
EAST CUT IT REMEMR TBACK
WHENE WAS VIC PRESIDENT, H
WAS TRAVELG T UKRAINE.THE STATDA
INVESTOR, WE VERY WORRIE
ABT HI VISIT.
THE WERE ABOUT -- WORRI
ABOUTHETORY AND THECONNECTIONS R
BIN THAT THEY MHT HAVE TO
EXPLN TT VICE PREDENT
BIDEN TOOKUESTNS THERE.>> Sean:F
ANYONE WITH THE LASNAMERUMP
HANTY, ALWAYS PUT SELF
IN TS POSITION,F I GOT THREE
AND HALF MILON DLARS FRO A
RUSSIAOLIGCH, FORMER FIRDY OMOSR
FROM KAZHSTAN OLIGARCH,ND AND
THEN THE WHOREE SMITH DEAL
WI NO EXPIENC AND THE BAN
OF CHINA.JOE BIDEDENIED EVER TA
NTER ABOUT ANYOREIGN
BUNESS DLINGS.
NOW  HAVE PTURES THAT HASEMERGEI
OUTT BUT MEETING WITHESE
FOREIGN BINES PARTNS OF
NTER.
MYUESTION TO YOU I, WHE'S
E COLICT OF INTERT
INVESTIGATN?
IFT WAS TRUMP I'MUESSING
THERE WOULENE AND WE WOULD
HEAR ABOUT IT EVERYECON
EVERY HO OF EVERY DAYN TH
DIA.
>> SE YOU WOULD.
IT WOULD BE P OF THEOLT
SHINON TIME, MSN.
ERE WAS AEEP CONICT OF
INRESTERE.THEY HE A RIGHT TO KNO
PRECISELYHAT HAPPENED.IT IS CEAT
THE MEDIA WAS TO CER UPHAT
VICERESINT BIDEN MAY HE
NEHESEONVERSATIONS TT HE
ULDAVE HAD WITH H SON.
ESE ARE IMPORNT, STRATEGIC
QUESONS R AMERICAN SURIT
>>ean: MR. SECRETA, WE
NE THE ADULTS BAN CHARGE
TH ACTUALLY G RESCT FROM
ESE COUNTRIES
RIT NOW THERE TESTING
I DON'T THINKE IS MEETING E
CHALLEE A